the true villain of descendants three
has been revealed and it's been hidden
in the teasers all along we piece
together all of the clues from the
teasers and the short story and we're
sure we've got it figured out so who is
the true villain in d3 the answer will
definitely shock you watch until the end
to find out
on three one two three major clues d3
fans have had to piece together bits and
pieces from the teasers that have slowly
been released by Disney there seems to
be several candidates for the true
villain of this movie the line between
friends and enemies is getting blurry
plus there are some major changes to a
few of the original characters from the
very first film in addition there are
new exciting characters being introduced
but one character is clearly missing
from all the teasers we think this is a
major clue and we'll get to that in a
minute first let's recap what we know so
far from the videos Disney has released
under the sea a descendants short story
and under the sea a descendant short
story we see that Emma is still after
mal there is a big reveal of Ursula
shell necklace we discovered that uma
now has the power to take over the body
of the person wearing the necklace that
left a lot of us wondering who else
uma will possess one thing that caught
our attention is that uma could be spine
on now through dizzy if you zoom in on
the part where dizzy is talking to mouth
you'll see a hidden clue mal is saying
that she found a blue orb in the woods
but sounded exactly like her dad looked
down at Dizzy's neck you'll see the
chain from umas necklace on dizzy so
it's possible that uma was using the
necklace to spy on mal she could have
learned about Hades from mal and Dizzy's
conversation maybe that prompted uma to
find a way to contact Hades and free him
on the condition that he helped her
dissolved the barrier around the isle
but is Hades the true villain let's
tackle the newest teasers to find out
more threat to Oregon now that we are
studying this teaser to find out who the
true d3 villain will be we noticed a few
very telling signs we know that the V
Ches all had to team up to fight a bunch
of armored dudes at our dawn prep but
who is controlling this army is uma
suddenly on mal side or are they just
frenemies for a hot second while they
fight these creepy clunky guys from the
short film it seems that uma will stop
at nothing to get back at now she warns
her that dangerous coming and that she
will never see where it's coming from so
did you miss somehow trick mal into
believing they were friends so she could
hit her with a surprise attack later on
it also appears that Audra is one
into the woods with Maleficent sector to
Duma possess Audrey if you look at
pictures Audrey is wearing the crown
from the beginning of this trailer so
maybe Audrey stole the crown along with
Maleficent staff out of the Museum of
cultural history mouths darkness in this
teaser mal and Ben are standing on the
balcony in front of the Arden kingdom
when mal suddenly has a dark permission
she is transported to a dark place that
looks like auradon she calls out for Ben
but when she finds him she discovers
that he has been turned to stone
we know from threat to our Adan that Ben
turns into a beast like his dad the
statue shows Ben and mid-transformation
he has facial hair just like he does in
the previous trailer right before he
goes full beast then we hear something
or someone whispers something before mal
is transported back to reality it sounds
like the voices whispering your future
so is this a warning about potential
future events now let's back up for a
minute at the beginning of the teaser as
Ben and mal are walking up to greet
their subjects we see fairy godmother in
the background
she looks very concerned as if she knows
what's coming fast forward to the end
and you'll see another one of dr. facile
ears cards with Arden on one end and the
Isle of the Lost on the other this leads
us to some other clues we've discovered
about who the true villain could be the
Big Sleep remember when they first
announced that Disney was making
descendants three if you think back to
the threat to our Adan teaser the first
thing we see is Sleeping Beauty's
spinning will you know the one she
pricked her finger on causing her in her
kingdom to fall asleep
well if Audrey did break into the museum
and still the scepter and Crown
maybe she snatched two the spinning
wheel - is it possible that Audrey
causes one of the vks to fall into a
deeper slumber in d3 some fans think
that person might be Evie but she looks
pretty awake in the teaser we catch our
first glimpse of dr. facile ears
daughter Celia and we got a peek at dr.
facile ears voodoo arcade so what do
Emma Hades Celia
dr. facile ear and Audrey all have to do
with each other could this be the
ultimate villain mashup and is there a
character we haven't seen that who could
turn out to be the true villain of
story there's a wicked rumor amongst the
savviest of The Descendants fans that's
pretty shocking but to find out who this
mystery character is you'll have to
watch until the end of this video here's
a hint this reveal is absolutely
petrifying
so who is the true villain in
descendants three let's investigate
further
dr. fossil beer from our previous videos
and fan threads you know that dr. fossil
ear may have a hand in Audrey's of
wicked transformation from sweet
princess of auradon to wicked girl in
the forest Sat picks revealed Audrey
rocking the distressed villain kid look
with pink hair dark makeup and some
interesting accessories not only is she
holding Maleficent staff and wearing
that crown from the museum but she is
also wearing a dragon necklace we know
from the animated movie The Princess and
the Frog the dr. fossil ear can change a
person's appearance if they wear an
enchanted necklace containing the blood
of the person they want to become is
Audrey's dragon necklace an enchanted
gift from the voodoo master himself
dr. facile ears got friends on the other
side so maybe that shadow places where
Mao goes when she sees Ben as a stone
statue in the movie
dr. facile ear holds up a card that
looks like a castle on the top half with
the shadow of a castle on the bottom
half that's what the card looks like at
the end of the teaser mouths darkness
with auradon on one half and the Isle of
the Lost on the other and we also know
that dr. facile ears card to show a
person who they want to be so did Audrey
visit dr. facile ear and see the card
from the first teaser with mal on it dr.
Brassell ears look has been kept a
secret so far he hasn't been in any of
the teasers that's a big indicator that
dr. facile ear is the one responsible
for turning Audrey into a villain but we
think the true villain could be someone
else
Audrey one thing that dr. fossil dared
didn't anticipate is how powerful Audrey
would become if she turned evil took on
some of Mouse power and stole Maleficent
scepter with the combined powers of mal
and Maleficent Audrey could be
unstoppable and after stealing the crown
she would be in charge of large armored
guards like the ones we saw in the
threat to our Adhan teaser so if Audrey
is the true villain and Dee
three what exactly is her plan is she
the one who opens the barrier to let all
the villains escape from the aisle maybe
she made a deal with dr. facile ear to
free him and the other villains if she
got to become Queen and return there's a
good chance that Audrey is out for
revenge against mal and Maleficent you
guys remember that awkward exchange
between mal and Audrey at the beginning
of the first movie right and mal did
still Ben from Audrey she's got a lot to
be mad about but after giving it some
thought we don't think Audrey is the
true villain and we're still piecing
together how she's involved with uma and
Hades uma at the end of descendants two
uma swirls around with her tentacles and
says the famous line you didn't think
this was the end of the story her evil
laugh for shadows dark things on the
horizon for descendants three and under
the sea a descendant short story puma is
up to her old tricks it's clear she has
not forgotten about her personal
vendetta with MAO and we also know that
uma can possess people with her shell
necklace so maybe it's Emma who enchants
Audrey and gets her to steal the crown
and staff from the museum
could she have possessed Audrey too said
Hades free as well we don't think so
that's because we see mal and Celia
opening a prison gates with a skeleton
key in the threat to our Adhan teaser so
Hades might be a prisoner of dr. facile
ear mal knows she has a big enemy to
fight and needs all the help she can get
so perhaps Celia steals her dad's keys
and helps mouse at Hades free but we
don't think uma is the true villain
either we see her teaming up with mal
and her crew to fight those armored
guards in the teaser so they might be
fighting something bigger than each
other but who what is the big threat to
our Adan Hades Hades is the god of the
underworld you can't get much darker
than that in the Disney animated film
Hercules he's a downright diabolical
villain from the teasers we know that he
has been locked up but now probably
wouldn't free him if she thought he was
evil we know that mal is having
premonitions about something dark and
mysterious threatening auradon so it's
possible that mal frees her dad Hades to
help them fight this terrible threats
could Hades actually be like mal a
villain turned hero if you watched the
teaser mouths darkness closely you'll
see that now has incorporated blue
streaks in her purple hair this is a
sign that she's embracing her newfound
parent again we're pretty sure she
wouldn't do that if he was totally evil
if Hades is Mel's dad that means that
mal is part goddess she could have new
powers we haven't seen yet and other
relatives too while dr. facile ears got
friends on the other side
Hades may have friends and relatives in
the Greek god realm that we've yet to
meet and this brings us to the biggest
top secret candidate we found for the
true villain in descendants three the
presence of Hades in the new movie is a
big clue that means that not only are
sorcerers and evil queens on the Isle it
also means that Greek gods and monsters
are lurking in the shadows as well in
the mouths darkness teaser mousies I've
been has been turned to stone do you
know who in the Greek mythology realm
has the power to turn people to stone if
you guessed Medusa you'd be right Medusa
is a Greek monster or Gorgon with snakes
for hair who can turn people to stone if
they look into her eyes there's also a
Gorgon and stranger things which could
explain the whole upside down feel and
Nas premonition
maybe Medusa is somehow related to Hades
could she be Myles and that's not
exactly how the Greek myth tells it but
Disney may take a few liberties for the
sake of the story maybe all of our Adan
is in danger of being turned to stone by
Medusa so Emma and now must team up with
Hades to stop her that would make Medusa
the true villain in descendants three
what do you think of this theory leave a
snake emoji in the comments if you agree
and if you have a theory and who the
true descendants three villain could be
don't be shy tell us in the comments
below thanks for checking out our latest
e3 video if you love the villain kids as
much as we do subscribe to our Channel
and give this video a big thumbs up
we'll see you next time on the things
[Music]